little remains of alexei vetrov's former
life in nizhny novgorod some pictures of
demonstrations some files on his laptop
Alexei tells us that he's the one
carrying the poster nostalgia and
bitterness that's what I feel when I
look at these pictures I've had to move
on my old life is over Alexei fled
Russia two years ago eventually he ended
up in this hostel in Kiev Ukraine each
of the rooms is shared by ten people for
his one and a half square meter is
Alexei pays 40 euros a month in rent in
Russia Alexei was a successful small
business owner and a political activist
which landed him in jail right now he's
headed for a charity organization in
Kiev it helps to organize a to eastern
Ukraine alexei volunteers here helping
war victims over the phone SOS this is
Alexei
hello what's your name and how can I
help you we accompanied Alexei to the
Russian embassy in Kiev alexei has been
here before to protest against Putin
it's a place that arouses mixed feelings
I'm not afraid here no but I still feel
somewhat uneasy in Ukraine because
Ukraine won't grant me asylum they won't
give me permission to stay here Alexei's
application for asylum was turned down
he still doesn't understand why and
believes the reasons he was given were
just flimsy excuses he's not alone in
his plight since the annexation of
Crimea Ukraine has approved only about
5% of a
applications from Russians next alexei
pays a visit to maxime boot kovitch a
human rights activist who helps people
obtain legal assistance he's been seeing
more and more Russian refugees according
to the United Nations Alexei meets the
criteria for refugee status
paradoxically the UNHCR recognizes me as
a refugee but Ukraine doesn't on the
basis of the very same conventions
maxine bucho vich says he's heard many
similar stories Ukraine's government
dismisses such allegations but it's
human rights Ombudsman admits it's a
complex situation we don't have a policy
of rejecting asylum applications coming
from people who have fled Russia there
is no such policy but there are some
difficulties associated with the current
legal situation in Ukraine this legal
situation also affects Russians who are
supporting Ukraine in the conflict with
Russia for the Ukrainian government they
are still here illegally
these military vehicles were captured in
the eastern Donbass region we meet
another Russian from Moscow who calls
himself Eva he's joined a right-wing
Ukrainian volunteer regiment that is
fighting the pro-russian separatists I
could be stopped on the street at any
time and asks for my papers I'd have to
show them my Russian passport and the
way things are now I could easily be
passed on to the security services and
deported some in Ukraine worried that
the Russian Secret Service might send in
fake refugees aid organizations are
familiar with these fears of course we
understand very well that there are some
security reasons probably that might be
the floor for their rejections from the
side of the migration service when the
applications are considered
for Russians who seek asylum in Ukraine
this mix of suspicion and bureaucratic
hesitation can be an insurmountable
hurdle
Alexei has his own explanation for why
it's so hard for Russians to obtain
Asylum status in Ukraine they have
plenty of political activists of their
own so why would they want Russian
activists the government sees them as a
danger Alex Hayes only choice right now
is to work as a courier he rarely earns
more than 50 or 60 euros a month
Alexei says he's worn out by the
constant struggle of his life here in
Kiev he's now hoping to move on and try
his luck with an asylum application in
some other country